- So has it been nice to have
Dwayne at home since retiring?
Is that nice?
(Dwayne clears throat)
- It has, it has, it has,
(Kelly laughs)
it has gotten nice.
- Mm-kay.
- You know, initially,
like, you know, we've been, you know-
our careers sort of
were on opposite coasts.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So we were
never really home together
for long stretches of time.
So it would be like every morning-
Oh! There you are. Um.
(Kelly laughs)
Okay. But over time- Look at his face!
Over time-
- [Kelly] It's probably weird for you too.
- It's awesome.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] It's like musicians.
- No one ever asks me, is it weird?
- No, no, you know why?
It's like, 'cause that's, like musicians,
like we're on the road all the time
and that can be hard,
like in a relationship.
And then you try and like almost
put yourself in this situation.
The family's already kind
of doing its own thing
while you've been gone.
- Yes.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Kelly] So that's hard.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I just had to be quiet
for like the first six months.
- (laughs) Good job.
- [Dwyane] Yeah.
Just shut up
- That's hard.
- and listen.
And now I found my space
now in the house, so.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yeah.
The rent I pay,
- [Kelly] That's tricky.
Yeah.
- Yeah,
I feel like I'm getting my money's worth.
- I get my money. (laughs and claps)
(audience claps)
I'm a part, I'm a part.
- Get my money's worth.